alors je suis désolé pour damner les
gilles mais ma déclaration sera plus
tout simple salut s'adressera à caroline
caroline voilà elle sait que je brûle
d'amour pour elle depuis déjà quelque
temps je n'oublie pas qu'elle en couple
avec le très charmant boris que j'aime
beaucoup un animateur charmant mais il
ya un moment faut arrêter de tortiller
du cul va falloir quand même se décider
donc on est le 14 février 2017
je respecte tout à fait ton couple c'est
très honorable
moi aussi j'ai envie de me mettre en
couple avec toi donc je te donne un an
jour pour jour pour régler cette affaire
dans les meilleures conditions à son
avantage financièrement c'est possible
se libère
si boris est d'accord évidemment mais je
sens qu'ils flottent un peu bavard et
est maurice dites moi qu'est ce que vous
avez envie de vous êtes avec caroline a
tout de suite
franchement c'est vrai pensez que c'est
la femme de votre vie c'est la femme
idéale elle est sublime elle est jolie
intelligente elle adore le zizi et pour
ph argent
vous aimeriez je dois aller vraiment
vous mettra caroline enfoncement dans un
an si caroline vous dis je
si vous voulez donc que caroline quitte
son maître pour 20 non mais oui oui oui
bah oui oui je le dis oui la belle va
pas le sens aimé ciel le kit vous voulez
l'étude selon m pour vous j'annoncerai
oui oui alors oui oui a dit le prévenu a
détruit je peux pas sauter quelques
jours mais oui tout de suite enfin quand
tu veux moi je suis moi je suis là mais
d'iquique elle a aidé sa cause ce qu'on
a ce qu'on laisse mourir alors qu il
s'étonna va lui faire chier celui là dit
le verdict alors dit oui je laime
secrètement c'est vrai vraiment pas
vraiment oui enfin oui nous redire ses
qualités ses qualités oui elle est jolie
intelligente très sensuelle les plus
belles jambes du paf
un regard un regard de chatte et
franchement
car deux chattes et en plus et est on
plus célèbres zizi et bien j'en ai un
le meilleur le meilleur moyen c'est de
demander à son mari elle coud la maladie
au coeur d antan
de 7 à 77 ans elle chante elle chante
insolence elles lui font mes cheveux
blonds les cheveux gris mes amis merci
jean michel merde je crois que j'ai un
petit compte à régler ce soir
[Applaudissements]
moi je parle bagarre samba gadjigo
risque est connu
besson
et pourtant
c'est pas grave alors boris à la baisse
ses attentes et c'est à lui que j'ai
chanté des hymnes du sardou serait mais
peut-être est-ce que ta femme est fan de
sardou et ouais c'est mon angoisse
totale alors et donc je dois pas qu'un
petit peu l'angoissé totale de
jean-michel merde
ah ben non il dit un an jour pour jour
moi je lui dis je vous donne une minute
moi à oui pour partir soit la partie
avec ta femme jean-michel qu'est ce que
vous avez à dire à maurice des bagarres
dont j'avais commencé sévère au ski je
crois il ya un truc très très chaud loup
qui s'était exilé la scène des bronzés
quand le mari arrivent avec les affaires
ne sera pas nécessaire mais les jalons
tel joyau mes chances je trouvais plus
épais là je suis assez rassuré monsieur
ne trouve plus mais il est très
sympathique je le respecte énormément
[Applaudissements]
une femme aussi merveilleuse que carly
un moment aussi faut essayer d'en faire
partager les autres et je crois qu'on
est venu avec les palaces a prévenu
boris peut-elle de donner sa chance à
bout de personnes à part on n'a pas la
même notion de l'amour
merci non non voilà le genre car ce que
l'on pense oui
le fan de bade du point
c'est défendre cette position non mais
c'est bien de remettre les choses et
boit et on me dit ça pourquoi parce que
j'ai présenté le bachelor ça m'est
arrivé une fois d'exploiter le bachelor
est d'ailleurs attention le bachelor
parce que ouais ça soit sa voiture de
résister sur le bachelor tant que père
dont elle console et à avis on en remet
à temps j'ai quand même laissé partir ma
femme seule au bout du monde avec des
mecs à poil vos résultats à poil et où
je les ai vues elles n'avaient pas tous
y faire revenir du foot c'est ça et jean
michel croc force que vous devriez vous
excuser omeyyades boris oui comment
jean-michel j'étais le gars michel est
ce que je dois m'excuser mais non c'est
pas amis
c'est un malade
j'adore j'adore le reste de la tenue
[Applaudissements]
d'abord il est très sympa très beau
couple on est au fond et pour jouer mais
on regardait c'est vrai on les envoie ce
corner il d'abord accepter un valentin
est la bienvenue et merci merci d'avoir
été là ça me donne vraiment super
ah là là il se passe toujours quelque
100 solutions et vous n'êtes pas au bout
d'un ce prêt